hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast setting up
next-generation sequencing for the needs
of routine molecular diagnostics with a
focus on the suitability of the gene
reader NGS system for lung cancer
patient presented by dr. Paul Hoffman
head of the laboratory of clinical and
experimental pathology at Pasteur
Hospital and head of the human bio Bank
unit at Pasteur Hospital
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kaijin for more
information about our sponsor visit them
at wwk again calm before I begin I want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen types of
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on that help
desk button located in a promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use that ask a question box
and let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me now in welcoming
our presenter dr. Paul Hoffman I will
now turn the presentation over to him
welcome sure okay
good morning everyone so this
presentation aims to show why it's
important to set up a next generation
sequencing approach in a molecular
pathology lab today and how to do that
so more specifically I will present our
own experience in our pathology
laboratory with a special focus
concerning the use
the gin reader NGS system for lung
cancer patient taking care
so here is the agenda of this
presentation and we start with a summary
of some major points concerning the lung
cancer in 2018 then a practical point of
view of using the gene reader NGS system
in a pathology lab and finally some
studies which compare different NGS
platforms so
tradition I would like to stress some
global points concerning the lung cancer
in 2018 and indeed it's important to
keep in mind what is a lung cancer
landscape in 2018 so it's well known
that lung cancer is still the main
Kentucky law work worldwide and despite
new promising therapy strategies the
prognosis of late stages lung carcinoma
is very bad with an overall survival of
less than 2% of the population five
years after the initial diagnosis
and despite many campaigns of prevention
to combat tobacco addiction in
particular among young people the lung
cancer death rates among European women
increased these last few years and it's
not worse is that now lung cancer is the
first cancer killer and women living in
certain European countries such as UK
apollon and probably in France and
moreover the estimated mortality
worldwide for 2020 shows that lung
cancer will be the fifth cause of death
at this time with a drama dramatic
increase of cases among the population
in the world
so
besides Etobicoke exposure we need to be
aware that one major cause of lung
cancer onset in the future will be
certainly air pollutant exposure and as
you you know it was claimed by the World
Health Organization in 2013 that air
pollution is now a type one carcinogenic
factor
the interjection of targeted therapy
into the clinical management of lung
adenocarcinoma has had a massive impact
of patient care with the discovery since
2004 of an increased number of genomic a
duration consequently
mutational analysis is critical in 2017
for treatment decision in clinical
routine practice so it will admitted
that people mandatory to give the right
drug to the right patient at the right
time but also by given the right
approach and I the right cost
take into consideration that the
turnaround time to get the result is
pivotal and should be less than 10 days
for couple of mutation and sis and since
some non energy wicked biopsy may be
used in certain situation we have also
to take into consideration the nature
and the quality of the bio source used
for genomic analysis
in this context many samples can be used
for molecular biology technologies such
as tissue biopsy cytological samples and
some Biofreeze in particular blood
samples
concerning the usefulness of wicked
biopsy for lung cancer patient taking
care the main interest is currently for
EGFR mutation testing but beside this
point many other opportunities will be
possible in the next future such as
liquid biopsy for screening of early
diagnosis of lung cancer and also large
genomic alteration analyzes using
next-generation sequencing technology
so the assessment of circulating tumor
DNA in lung cancer patient can be made
using different technologies showing
various sensitivities but also different
specificities
for example the drop track digital PCR
method which is best for individual
point mutation detection and which needs
a minimal minimal bio informatics
development in the lab currently there
is to approve companion diagnostic test
for GFR detection in liquid biopsy this
is the terrorist error string test and
the kaaba's test we took it but finally
NGS method can be developed from
circulating tumor DNA using different
panels in theory this approach allows
the detection of point mutations
rearrangements and genomic amplification
I will focus this presentation to lung
cancer patient taking care and as shown
here in a recent issue of the journal of
Clinical Oncology molecular testing
guideline for the lung cancer patients
includes first the need for EGFR
mutation detection I can ross one
rearrangements detection and deer as
mutation detection of course beside PDL
one immunohistochemistry testing
moreover also biomarkers such as earth
to mutation red and n track
rearrangements and magma tation and
amplification are currently under
investigation as predictors or response
to targeted therapy
so for molecular testing in a routine
practice q different strategies can be
set up for certain solid cancer patient
person taking care first strategy using
targeted analyzes and secondly strategy
using large panel sequencing
as shown on the slide for targeted
analyzes
devices can be used with different
sensitivity efficiency allowing us to
get the results with different
turnaround times for panel sequencing
different NGS sequencing systems can be
used routinely from different companies
such as the my sec from Illumina the PGM
Ion Torrent and now the has five from
demo and finally the generator
sequencing system from qianjin
so now the second part of my talk will
focus on the use of the gin reader for
NGS approach mainly for solid tumors
genomica duration and we set up this
generator system in an overlap
there is a gene reader system and in our
experience the workflow takes five days
until the diagnosis can be made in our
in-house pipeline protocols and regions
use in the different steps of the
pipeline have to be synchronized
globally there is a very low hands-on
time less than 10 hours but the ends of
time of nearly 60 hours
so different application are currently
available and we started to develop in
our lab some of this application in
particular the actionable insights tumor
panel of course other applications
include some panel from lung cancer and
suit and very soon amyloid panel since
most of our activity is focusing lung
cancer patients we think to use very
soon the UM I or in one si allowing
detecting mutation and rearrangements
both in tissue and also in the keyed
biopsy
so this table shows the number of
variants detectable according to the um
I DNA panel and to the QR Act a itv2
panel as you can see all the genomica
durations of interest for lung cancer
are present in both panel with more
variants detectable in the a itv2 panel
you
for summarizing Michigan
presentation we can say that the
targeted NGS workflow of the June reader
system has low hands-on time but the
relatively high end of time currently it
demonstrated a high run performance and
high a currency in mutation calling the
gene readers allows the integration of
an automatic data transfer and automatic
analysis and an easy interpretation for
the team in the lab so in this context
the enterprise interpretation so the QCA
enables to rip up easily the mutant with
a potential path of pathogenic impact
according to the previously described
PAP ASCO guidelines so for us it's an
easily accessible technology for all
molecular pathology laboratories
so for better evaluating the generator
NGS system different comparative studies
have been recently published and I
decided now to select a couple of them
made from some investigators of the
Institute of Pathology in Cologne
Germany was set up in order to compare
the generator and an alternative
in-house NGS platform based on the
aluminum Isaak sorry tumors coming from
different pathologies such as lung colon
gastric carcinoma and melanoma - we're
including this comparative work the
panel used on the generator was the
actionable inside chemo panel described
previously
this quite busy table shows the time
cross of the of the in-house pipeline
and to gin with the NGS system workflow
so numerous automatic steps reduce the
hands-on time of the generator work rule
but one of the major points is certainly
an easy step for data analysis
interpretation and reporting with the
generator system
these graphs show the very nice
concordance between the in-house
workflow using the my sec platform and
the gin reader system in particular for
the direct labor can see comparison so
high concordance was obtained for 45
clinical different violence
we recently made in our lab another work
and it was a comparison study between
the results obtained using the uncle
mine panel on the PGM ion turrent and
the gin with the actionable insights
targeted panel so as shown here the ion
on combined panel contains 22 genes
the gene reader actionable insight panel
contains 12 genes so we did a comparison
only on six genes
however we highlight two points first
the need of Jeannie amount is quite much
lower when using the on command panel
and currently the actionable insight
panel is for research use only while the
ion uncle on command panel is COI SCE IV
d panel if requested by the delegates of
the webinar the detail overview of the
different mutation detected by the
generator NGS sequencing platform is now
available on this recent published by
paper from investigate and these two
Gators in Cologne Germany
[Music]
you
shortly here is the description of the
lung cancer patient cohort used for the
comparison study between the uncle mine
and the actionable inside panels that we
did in our study this comparison was men
on 90 lung adenocarcinoma of different
stages and including retrospective and
prospective cohorts of patients this
graph shows the density of tumor cell
content distribution between the
retrospective co-opt
in blue and the prospective co-opt in
pink
there is a description of mutational
status of the 90 page patients with
advanced non small cell lung cancer
included in our study we had a slide our
assessment of the EGFR mutation in the
positive cohort
probably due to a higher selection in a
nonsmoker population
I've shown here both sequencing systems
using this 2d demonstrated perfect
concordance for the overlapping genes
with no false positive and no false
negative results for missense mutation
deletion complex deletion and inception
we noted to a very nice correlation of
the allele frequency for all mutations
from between the generator and the ion
PGM both in the retrospective co-opt on
the Left panel and on the positive co-op
on on the in the right panel of this
slide
finally as shown here the coverages at
the site of mutation in the hist
respective genes for the generator and
the ion PGM were quite similar both in
the retrospective and in the prospective
cohort of patients
shortly these graphs showed that though
of a possibility of the essay perform on
the iron PGM or on the gin reader was
nice here for the assessment of the
allele frequency of the Kiera's q61 h
mutation
once again this figure shows a
comparison of the workflow of
different times needed for the iron PGM
workflow in contracts to the generator
platform
subtle graph shows comparison of the
different steps needed for nucleic acid
extraction to diagnosis as well as
required chemicals and equipment
depicted in blue so briefly the ends on
time in gray in the upper graph is lower
for the Ion Torrent PG epgm
than for the gin reader system scenes in
the lower graph however the time hands
of time was lower with the gin with the
system so taken taken together in this
comparison study we found that the total
time for from start to diagnosis was a
little bit longer for the for the
generator system compared to the I on PG
m system
finally we found that the gene reader
system was quite easier to use for both
technicians and molecular pathologists
on my of my lab because of a fully
automatic automated trust ability for
all workflow steps and because of the
use of the gene read link
you
at the end of this presentation and as
some end points I think it is very
important to say that the complete
workflow for next-generation sequencing
should be set up in any pathology lab by
2018 in particular for taking care of
late-stage non small cell lung carcinoma
patients
context we demonstrated that the
generator system can show real benefits
of rapid workflow integration and we
strongly believe that the generator can
avoid the pain of harmonizing a stream
solution the drain Jojen reader can save
the expense of specialized resources to
develop and and optimize a bio
informatics pipeline and the gin reader
probably can help us to realize a true
solution for sequencer performance that
is pre verified within an entire
workflow and finally the gin with our
system can document the full chain of
custody from sample to inside and this
could be of some help forgetting as an
example and accreditation for doing NGS
routinely in a pathology laboratory
thank you for your attention
thank you dr. Hoffman for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window and type that
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for so let's get started
let's check out our first questions
coming in from our audience members dr.
Hoffman our first question is how long
did it take to get the NGS workflow
established in your lab yes it's a nice
question so of course the answer is
depends of what you will use as NGS
system in the lab so for me at the
beginning we set up different NGS
systems so I would say that for me it
took around 2 months to set up an NGS
workflow but if we want it now to set up
the NGS workflow by using the generator
system I will say that this time will be
reduced and it will be around one month
to do that thank you very much and our
next question is what is the biggest
improvement through this workflow the
biggest improvement is probably to get
many mutation results at the same time
in a short time we say that is quite
important that beside EGFR mutation
detection of our arrangement detection
is pivotal for lung cancer patient to
try to detect other mutation for
possession getting some targeted
therapies such as for example therapy
against red rearrangement or ros1
rearrangement and also Kiera's if it's
possible so it's very important to have
this
results in one step I mean to try to
detect all the mutation and all the
arrangement through an NGS system I
think it's very important to improve the
possibility for our patient to to have
the best therapy
thank you dr. Hoffman and I want to
thank our live audience members for
their questions coming in and remind
them that any questions not answered
today can be answered via email we have
one more question that has come in do
you need a bio information to interpret
the results and how do you report them
yeah it's a it's a pivotal question I
mean it depends of course of your NGS
system I I will prefer to have a
bioinformatician
in my laboratory to interpret the
results since it's a very specific area
of Medicine right now so if we have some
NGS systems such as s5 or thermo Fisher
or the my SEC of Illumina I think is
definitively mandatory to have a
bioinformatician to interpret the result
but for example if we want to set up an
NGS system using the gene Widow's system
is quite easier to interpret the results
so we can you can avoid to have a
bioinformatician dedicated in the lab to
interpret the reserve so it's depend
definitively of what kind of system you
want to set up in your lab right and dr.
Hoffman thank you so much for your
presentation today and for your
important research would you like to
provide the audience members with any
closing remarks
now I think it's a we say that it's now
pivotal to to set up an nga system in
any pathology laboratory or any
molecular pathology laboratory around
the world and the critical step right
now for our patient to have the
possibility to get any mutation results
or resonance result as soon as possible
we see in less than 10 days when we get
the biopsy in the laboratory so thank
you very much
dr. Hoffman thank you again for your
presentation I'd also like to thank our
sponsor kaijin for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing through September 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
this announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye